Hey, this is sort of funny.
Donald Trump did a press briefing over the
weekend once again at his Bedminster Golf
Club.
And much like last weekend, some of his supporters
who were guests at the club were allowed to
go to the briefing.
And it's another example of Trump generating
these sort of rally like atmospheres with
friendly crowds, even though he's supposed
to be seriously briefing America and the press
about that thing called the corona virus pandemic,
which killed 7000 people in the last six days.
It's sort of like a rally atmosphere with
his supporters cheering in the background.
It's weird, but the crazy thing is that even
the friendly crowd and the cheering couldn't
make Trump look sensible, and he instantly
fell apart even in front of a friendly crowd.
So let's look at some of the clips.
Trump started by talking about how cases are
going down despite testing, which continues
to expose that Donald Trump is very, very
confused about how testing relates to cases.
And by the way, there were 55000 cases the
day before Trump did this press briefing.
Listen to what Donald Trump had to say.
Nearly 85 percent of jurisdictions all across
our country are reporting a very steep decline
in cases.
And that's despite the fact that we have the
number one testing program anywhere in the
world.
We're up to almost 70 million tests far beyond
any other country.
This week, cases nationwide have declined
by six percent.
So, of course, Trump doesn't get it.
More testing reduces cases over the long term
because people know they have it.
They know they're contagious.
They stay home.
That ship has sailed.
What?
He's just not going to understand that or
he's refusing.
He's at least pretending not to understand
that.
So then it starts to get ugly very quickly.
Trump here suggests that the numbers on the
virus are so good that he must win.
In other words, how could a president who
has such great numbers on the virus not be
reelected?
That's where Donald Trump's mind is, that
Iran would love to have me defeated if if
I win, which I hope to win.
How can you not when you see numbers like
this both on the virus and on the economy.
And we should win.
We should all be keep this incredible thing
going.
And I built it once and I'll build it again.
I've already done.
I think the hardest part is done in terms
of the economy, and that's with or without
additional funds.
Remember that as a country we have the eighth
most cases per capita in the world.
If you don't include tiny countries which
can throw off the data, the U.S. has the sixth
most cases per capita in the world in terms
of deaths.
We have the tenth most deaths per capita in
the world.
Again, if you exclude places like San Marino
and Andorra because they have tiny populations
where the numbers were just a few deaths per
capita is very high.
If you exclude those, we are eighth worst
in the world in terms of per capita deaths.
And Trump says, how could you not reelect
a president with numbers so good?
And at the end there, you might have heard
Trump start to say we're doing great with
or without stimulus money.
Like Trump seems to be suggesting here that
the second stimulus, which is being debated
right now, it may not even be necessary.
Things are just fine, which just shows how
disconnected he is from reality.
He's asked about that specifically.
And here he says, if we can do it or not,
do the second stimulus either way is fine
for him.
I guess he means listen to me.
Listen to me.
My people are doing very good and my people
call me.
They're in the office.
They call me.
They call me when it's right.
Nobody knows the deal better than I do.
When it's right, I'll meet.
But right now, it's not right.
They want a trillion dollars to bail out.
Badly run states state that the Democrat the
rule.
I mean, they're Democrat states.
Will something happen?
Possibly.
But I want to tell you, the country is doing
very well right now.
We can live very happily with it, without
it.
But I'd like to do it because I want to give
money to the people.
I like how Trump says we can be happy with
or without another stimulus.
Record unemployment.
Highest GDP drop on record last quarter.
Businesses still not functioning fully.
Schools closed are going remote increasingly
as the virus spreads.
But Trump.
Fine with or without a second stimulus.
Good to know, right?
I'm glad he's fine with it either way.
Trump is then asked about polling, which doesn't
look particularly good for him.
And Trump is just rambling about.
There are lots of boaters, people with boats
who like Trump and have Trump flags on their
boats.
It's rivers and oceans, thousands and thousands
of boats.
It's called Voters for Trump, voters for Trump
Pence.
There's signs all over.
Some of the boats have 10 flags on them.
They're incredible.
There's thousands.
We did nothing to do this as this is just
generic.
It just happened.
The thing is that, you know, the white Florida
boat owner demographic isn't enough to win
it for Trump.
He may have enough to win it.
That's important.
But the boaters in the Intercoastal are not
enough to win it for Donald Trump.
And here again, Trump goes into the stuff
about mail in voting, saying we might not
know the results of the November election.
Not for days, not for weeks, never months.
We might not know it for years.
If we are going to have an election that takes
place on a beautiful day, November 3rd, and
usually at the end of the evening, they say
Donald Trump has won the election.
Donald Trump is your new president.
Whatever they say, you know what?
You're not going to notice possibly if he
really did it right.
For months or for years, because these ballots
are all going to be lost.
They're going to be gone.
Then just take a look at a smaller basis.
But it's great tests.
We're doing tests.
I mean, these are you could call them polls.
You could call them tests.
Look at what's happening all over the country
where you have universal mail and what the
ballots are lost.
This fraud, this theft, it's it's happening
all over the place.
Now, we're going to do it with this whole
vast, big section of the country.
It's crazy.
Think about how insanely hyperbolic that is.
All the ballots will be lost and we won't
know who won four years.
Consider how ridiculous that is.
On what planet would we not know the election
results for years?
And by the way, does Trump know that if that
happens, he stops being president on January
20th?
It's not clear that someone has actually said
that to Donald Trump.
And of course, realistically, if there are
a lot of mail in ballots and they have to
be postmarked by Election Day, could take
a few days to get counted.
It might take a few days to have the final
results.
And if it's really close, we might not know
who is going to be president in January until
like November 8th.
That's not the worst thing in the world.
Let's get it right.
In many countries, you don't know the results
at midnight.
We think that we should.
That doesn't have to be the way it is.
Then Trump is asked about birther ISM 2.0,
which is about Kamala Harris.
Is Kamala really eligible to be president?
Trump has a chance to denounce it, but he
does not want to say now that Kamala Harris
is eligible to run and the vice president
for president based on the warning.
So I have nothing to do with it.
I read something about it and I will say that
he is a brilliant lawyer, that I guess he
wrote an article about it.
So I know nothing about it.
But it's not something that bothers me.
Certainly do that.
It creates.
Why do you say that?
I just don't know about it.
But it's not something that we will be pursuing.
Let me put it differently.
You know, let me be.
Don't tell me what I know.
Let me put it differently.
To me, it doesn't bother me at all.
I don't know about it.
I read one quick article.
The lawyer happens to be a brilliant lawyer.
As you probably know, he wrote an article
saying that could be a problem.
It's not something that I'm going to be pursuing.
I just told you, I have not gone into it in
great detail.
If she's got a problem, you would have thought
that she would have been vetted.
You would have felt that she would have been
vetted by Sleepy Joe.
Yeah, go ahead.
He's like, you know, I don't know much about
this, but the guy who wrote the article questioning
whether Kamala can be V.P. because to be V.P.,
you have to be eligible to be president.
That guy is brilliant.
That guy's credentials are super, super good.
And.
And you'd think Joe Biden would have vetted
her.
But, you know, I can't I don't know anything
about that.
Birther ISM 2.0 is building and it's arguably
going to continue building if other strategies
don't go well here.
Trump does what I call the sir routine.
The search routine is we have a name.
It's crazy that we have a name.
The search routine is when Trump retells a
story of someone saying something to him that
is advantageous to him.
And he'll say, you know, they came to me and
they said, Sir, blah, blah, blah.
You can almost guarantee it didn't happen
the way Trump claims it happened when he does
the search routine.
I want.
I say that I want college football to come
back.
These are strong, healthy and credible people.
These are people that want to play football
very badly, a great, great talent.
Quarterback Trevor Lawrence called me on two
days ago.
I spoke to him couple of times.
He said, Sir, I want to just tell you we want
it back.
We want to play.
And he's an incredible quarterback, as you
know, from an incredible school, Clemson.
And he's going to have a very good future
in the NFL.
Sir, they told me they came to me.
Sir, sir, please start college football.
OK, some quick ones here.
Donald Trump still continues to refer to the
1918 flu pandemic as happening in 1917.
I'm not agree with Dr. Robert Redfield, who
earlier this week said if America doesn't
follow, public health guidelines would could
be in store or one of the worst off we've
ever faced.
Health perspective?
No, I mean, you can't compare it to 1917.
That was incredible.
I was.
That was the worst ever by far.
How as you look at that.
They lost possibly 100 million people.
No, I don't agree with that.
But weirdly, Trump says that some people call
his own secretary of defense Mark.
Yes.
Spur as opposed to Mark Asper.
Just like a very weird moment, Defense Secretary.
Mark, do you have confidence in his leadership
there?
Mark Esper, did you call him?
Yes, sir.
Oh, OK.
Some people call him.
Yes.
No, I'll get along with him.
I'll get along with him.
Fine.
He's fine.
And then here again, it's that raucous atmosphere
that Donald Trump loves.
Even if it's supposed to be a serious press
briefing, he actually suggests that he might
fire his entire cabinet if he gets reelected.
He then dissembles into rambling and walks
off the stage to the applause of his club,
going mostly mask wearing sycophants saying,
go as far as your cabinet goes, do you think
you'll see more turnover in your capital?
I don't know.
I think for next year, I mean, generally speaking,
a lot of times I understand when if we win
a president who will ask for the resignation
of everybody and then bring back the people
he wants, that's happened before Steve and
I could see something like that happening.
I think that makes sense.
No, I have a very good cabinet.
I mean, with few exceptions, I wouldn't say
I'm thrilled with everybody, frankly, but
I have overall, I think we have a very good
cabinet.
I think this I will say this.
No administration.
None.
First, three and a half years has done anywhere
near what we've done.
300.
We will have at the end of the first term,
300, maybe more federal judges, including
Court of Appeals to Supreme Court justices.
Nobody has done this.
Take a look at it.
Take a look at what we've done.
The biggest tax cuts in history, biggest regulation
cuts in history, rebuilt our military, took
care of our vets.
We have a 91 percent approval rating from
the vets.
Nobody's ever had a 91 percent approval rating
before.
A week I guarded the 2nd Amendment.
They want to destroy the Second Amendment.
Take a look at Carmela.
And as you know, Joe has no control over anybody.
He has no control over himself.
Okay.
Thank you very much, everybody.
That's considered in 2020, among trumpet's,
a corona virus press briefing from the president
of the United States.
As if it's a serious thing, the cheering is
just too much.
I would love to interview the people there
right after they're done.
Cheering and Trump walks off.
What made you cheer?
What exactly were you cheering for?
What did you hear from the president that
you liked so much that made you cheer as he
walked off stage?
And I've said before, even in friendlier and
friendlier settings, Trump is on Fox and Friends,
a friendly setting, and it goes terribly.
I'll talk about that later.
Trump is on Hannity.
It's a it's his friend.
And even Hannity can't make Trump look good.
A press briefing at his own club with his
supporters cheering and he still looks like
he has absolutely no idea what's going what's
going on.
There is no setting friendly enough that can
make Donald Trump look good.
At this point in time, we're going to have
more coverage of this on our Instagram page,
which is David Pakman show on Instagram.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Dot Pacman.
Coming up next.
So much more.
Very busy day as the Democratic National Convention
gets started tonight.
I will be streaming starting at eight forty
five p.m. Eastern Time,